we will take the family page out to  inheritance that home that you've worked  for it belongs to you and your family  you should be able to pass it on to your  children and with the Conservatives the  taxman will not get his handle thank you  very much we can paint the years for  abolition of inheritance tax and do I  take David Cameron seriously in the five  years they've been in government they  have not up the threshold but I don't  really take them seriously well it will  not be a priority for SMP MPs to offer  tax breaks to people who are already  doing very well we're gonna tackle tax  avoid and crack down on the hedge funds  and abolishing the non domiciled tax  status I'm gonna challenge the Tories  and match us it's right it's fair and  label delivered Labour's point of view  there Emily coniferous of the  complacency of the service we're coming  click nice thank you happy